[Musique]
c'est un miracle qu'il soit encore en
vie il risque d'être sujet à des sautes
d'humeur de l'agitation des épisodes de
confusion on a le droit de fumer ici
absolument pas la peine le docteur
écrivain tu accepterais d'écrire ma
biographie une biographie ce que je te
propose c'est de venir t'installer chez
moi dans ma famille jusqu'à ce que tu es
de quoi te retourner
Jacky Jacqueline la seconde femme de
Floyd c'était une brillante avocate
du premier mariage de Floride
il me faisait penser à moi
plus ou moins très bien bienvenue dans
la famille
tous les deux à l'écriture d'un livre
j'ai fait beaucoup de grandes choses
dans ma vie tout le monde découvrira ses
exploits comme moment sera venu pour
l'armée le gouvernement etc
on y viendra je suis désolé j'ai
toujours pas retrouvé mes esprits tu
fais des
ça va
est-ce que c'est toi bien sûr qui
veux-tu que ce soit
[Musique]
Floyd je vous ai cherché partout merci
c'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg